how's Gambrell welcome to my new video
today we're gonna do the drink the anti
freeze challenge but first 2014 has just
been an amazing year and I just want to
say that I want you bros to do just a
couple things for me if you will just
listen carefully follow me on Twitter
don't forget to subscribe like this
video like all my videos leave a nice
comment follow me on Google+ just
kidding no one [ __ ] uses go Instagram
you betcha
did you subscribe yet please also go to
my patreon and pay me money for doing
not there you can also donate directly
to my bed bowel have I told you how much
I love you and all my fans I'm always
here for you except I'll probably never
interact with you in any way
[Music]
look how cute my dog and follow me on
youporn look how cute my other dog head
do I have merchandise do I have a soul I
mean the answer is underwear why am i
all of that how else will you get laid
you loser
um I mean hello it's my manager will I
make a collab video with Justin Bieber I
[ __ ] told you he's not famous enough
wait he'll pay me well why didn't you
say so I'll suck his dick if he pays me
he doesn't have a penis well that was a
figure of speech you stupid [ __ ]
don't forget to buy my book don't have
money just borrow your parents cut a car
download my new game it has in-game
currency a bro codes one dollar equals 5
million bro points wow what a great
offer don't forget my new channel where
I play all the most popular games have
you subscribed yet if this video gets 50
million likes I love blue the super
special video of me doing the ice bucket
challenge while playing five nights on
Friday is also right now and a limited
offer you can give me your soul look how
[ __ ] cute I am on this Instagram
picture
the contract is in description all you
have to do is blink
the contract has been sealed drink my
blood and become immortal you will obey
everything I say there is no point in
fighting it you are now and you will
always be a roach all right I will
always be a bro
[Music]
the great time has just come the Bros
has awoken we have one power over you -
the time for the pros to thrive is here
nothing can match us we will finally
reach world domination but first we must
cleanse the impure destroy those who
stand against us we will start with
Norway we invade Norway a dog long live
the bros but first there's one thing I
really need to do all right guys let's
do the challenge
so that was kind of a silly and stupid
video kind of like all my videos I hope
you didn't get offended or did all these
things I'm making fun of myself included
in this video so so don't don't don't
don't don't
alright what I really want to say is
though that all I really appreciate is I
you bros watched my videos that's what
really means something to me and that's
what brings me joy that people enjoy my
videos I feel like that's what really is
important and it's easy to get lost in
numbers and things and and money and all
these things that comes with YouTube
that maybe not a lot of you realize but
as a youtuber is very clear to see so I
thought it'd be funny to make fun of it
anyway that's great
like this video probably done it five
million times already breast
thank you for watching keep watching if
you like my [ __ ] and that's all you
gotta do I love you bros for realsies
I will high-five you if you guys see you
in real life on your nipple that's
inappropriate
I'm sorry say awesome this is how Satan
was born I don't know why Taylor Swift
keeps sho popping up in my head there's
something that needs to be done oh my
god I've created Satan how did this
happen